a gradually through the title of the
workshop for multi-group fairness to
validity and the Amanda will take us all
the way there
thank you yeah hi everyone I'm really
excited to be here today and talk about
validity and decision making algorithms
and feel free to jump in throughout the
presentation with any questions you
might have
so I'm going to start uh today by
sharing a story involving one of my
favorite children's book characters
Amelia Bedelia so Amelia Bedelia is a
housekeeper for her employer Mrs Rogers
and to Mrs Rogers great frustration
Amelia Bedelia follows her request quite
literally so when Mrs Rogers asked her
to draw the drapes Amelia Bedelia later
hands her a hand-drawn picture of the
drapes
so Amelia Bedelia follows instructions
quite literally
and just like Amelia Bedelia algorithms
to do exactly what we tell them to do
even though often what we actually
wanted them to do was something else
however unlike Mrs Rogers we often don't
get immediate clear feedback that the
model did something other than what we
intended so in today's talk we'll see
how validity can be a really useful lens
for identifying and addressing this
misalignment between what we intend for
the model to do and what it actually
does
so today's talk we'll discuss validity
why it's important for decision making
algorithms then we'll see how to
identify and manage validity issues and
finally consider some open challenges
so what is validity uh when I'm using
the word validity I'm meaning a
scientific or statistical validity that
is we'll say a measure is valid if it
assesses the concept that we intend for
it to measure
so this idea of validity has a long
literature in the social sciences
particularly psychometrics and
experimental research and more recently
human computer interaction
so you know this might seem a little bit
abstract but hopefully we can try to
make this more concrete with a few
examples that you might already be
familiar with
uh first we'll start off by looking at
the SAT so the SAT used for college
admissions used to include analogy
questions
so these questions would say something
like Runner is to Marathon and the
correct answer that they would want
students to choose would be orsman is to
Regatta
and the idea was that this question
would assess the relationship between
these Concepts but critics pointed out
that instead this question was perhaps
more likely to actually assess someone's
socioeconomic privilege which kids had
actually had the opportunity to attend
regattas
so in other words they argued that these
analogy questions were not valid
assessments of language skills and they
removed these from the SCT
so as our second example we have
election polling
uh it's of course difficult to obtain a
representative sample of the population
for polls because people vary in how
easily reachable and responsive they are
to polling
and uh also the active pulling can
itself influence outcomes people may be
less likely to go out and vote when
their candidate is predicted to win by a
significant margin
so given these challenges we could
debate how valid polls are at predicting
election outcomes
now when I ask the question how valid uh
this departs from how we use the word
valid in conversational settings where
we would refer to the binary concept of
something either being invalid or valid
but actually this notion of validity
that I'm going to talk to you about
today is not something that we can prove
holds decidedly instead we should think
of assessing whether there is strong or
weak evidence in support of this claim
okay so let's now consider what validity
means for decision making algorithms
so we've already seen in some of today's
talks that predictive algorithms are
used to inform uh decisions in many
consequential domains where it will be
critical to consider issues of validity
and I'll just note that in my talk I'm
going to refer to these algorithms uh
using the terms machine learning tool
algorithm and predictive model
interchangeably
so what does validity mean for decision
making algorithms this means that we're
asking to what extent the model predicts
the quantity that we think it does
and this seemingly basic question of
whether the model is actually doing what
it's supposed to do is really important
it doesn't always hold when it doesn't
hold it has a lot of important
implications for things we care about
like fairness
and in practice it's not as easy to
assess as we might expect
many models will fail to meet this
requirement due to unaddressed data
challenges or problem formulation issues
there's a growing body of researchers in
machine learning and statistics
highlighting serious validity issues
for instance an in-depth investigation
of algorithms used for screening job
applications by Manish ragavan and
co-authors describes a number of
validity concerns
in hiring the outcome that we'd like
ideally to measure and predict is
whether someone will be successful in
the job if they're hired
but the challenge lies in how we
operationalize that and what Target
outcome we choose to do so can encode
biases
so a Natural Choice might be to say like
let's look at their evaluation uh the
evaluation of their job performance by a
manager
but this can reflect human biases that
may favor in-group colleagues
and then further complicating things is
the recent expansion of alternative
assessments for hiring that use games or
video to purportedly assess job relevant
skills
this has generated a lot of controversy
because people debate whether these
types of games and videos actually have
predictive validity for job relevant
skills so in this example an applicant
describes themselves in a 30 second clip
that's used to produce scores that the
company claims describes how adventurous
culture resourceful that applicant is
researchers have also highlighted uh
potential misalignments in child welfare
domains between what the predictive
model is assessing which uh in this
setting is the likelihood of a proxy
outcome for long-term risk versus what
the social workers are assessing and
have historically been assessing which
is immediate safety concerns for the
child
so although the agency did extensive
evaluations of their model and shared
public reports showing that their
predictive model has a high level of
accuracy researchers found that the
workers themselves perceive this model
to be incompatible with their actual
decision making objectives because they
doubted the validity of the tool so this
example highlights that you know at
first when we start talking about this
you might think are we saying something
about accuracy but you can't have a
model that is both accurate but where
people question the validity for the
actual tasks that they want to do and
when we fail to properly investigate the
validity of these tools we may find
ourselves susceptible to what debraji
and Lizzy Kumar and co-authors call the
AI functionality fallacy so this is that
too often the functionality of AI is
taken for granted without proper
investigation or justification
this can lead to harms when the task is
practically or conceptually impossible
when the design or implementation issues
go unaddressed and when the model's
abilities are misrepresented or
overstated among several other failure
modes that they detail in the paper and
so we'll see a number of these issues
reappear later in our talk
another area of the machine learning and
statistics literature where we see
attention on validity issues
concerns the mismatch between data
that's available to train and test
algorithms versus the target population
that we actually want to deploy the tool
on
for instance risk assessments are often
trained and tested on a specific
geography but then widely deployed to
other geographies
and even when a geographically
representative data set is used they're
often structural issues with the
decision-making tasks that can create
this mismatch for instance labeled
outcomes may only be selectively
available for a bias set of the
population like in consumer credit
lending for instance where repayment or
default outcomes are only observed for
applicants whose loan was granted which
is generally not a representative sample
of the full population of loan
applicants on which the tool will be
used yeah
yeah yeah that's a great question yeah
so so they're Computing the accuracy
with respect to this proxy of longer
term risk so that model is trying to
predict this and they see how well it
predicts it and they say there's a high
measure of accuracy but the social
workers still doubt the validity of it
because they are they actually are not
interested in that proxy outcome but are
that interested in immediate safety uh
concerns
all right
okay so sometimes risk assessments are
trained and tested on one geography and
then deployed on other ones uh and also
we could have selection issues when we
only have labeled outcomes available for
a selectively biased set of the
population like in consumer credit
lending where we only observe repayment
outcomes for applicants whose loan was
granted
this mismatch can be especially
problematic when we're trying to assess
how well the algorithm performs uh
because on validation sets the algorithm
may look really good we may again see
really high accuracy but when we deploy
it to another uh population we may then
observe degraded performance
relatedly the standard approach of
randomly splitting data into trained
validation and test sets may not work
well for settings with temporal shift or
dependencies researchers have pointed
out how this can lead to data leakage
and overestimation of what performance
will be in real world settings where the
data distribution changes over time
and they've highlighted the importance
of constructing trained test splits to
be representative of how data will be
used in practice so for instance we
always have temporal shift so if we have
a data set that maybe spans 15 months we
should maybe you should train on the
first 12 months and then test on the
last three to actually be representative
of what it will look like when you
deploy it in the future
so okay so this gives you a sense that
there's this distributed literature
identifying validity issues in both
particular high-stakes domains like
hiring but also identifying General
issues across domains and these issues
can originate as early as the initial
problem formulation stages
so how can we anticipate these well we
might hope for a way to map the
landscape of validity issues that
commonly arise in validity uh
algorithmic decision making context
so that is is there a framework that we
can use to anticipate and address
validity issues
okay so as a reminder when I when I'm
talking about validity uh we're
interested in the extent to which the
model does what it purports to do and
we'll now translate ideas from validity
Theory and the social sciences to our
algorithmic decision making setting and
this process will highlight three common
reasons why validity can fail to hold in
practice
yeah
um are there any examples of where
validity actually holds you've given
like lots of reasons why it's really
really difficult are there any positive
examples of machine learning being used
yeah I mean I would go back to that
slide where I say
I say like a yes or no concept it's
something where you're presenting strong
or weak evidence so perhaps if I could
read frame your question it would be
something like is there a setting where
we have strong evidence that machine
learning uh that's the machine learning
model is valid
well or that there's some you know this
is a theory so is there like some even
toy model where we can prove solidity of
algorithms
foreign
that's an interesting question I mean I
think of validity as being very tied to
the context in which the model is going
to use but I think it would be
interesting to kind of consider what
like looking at this through a
theoretical lens would illuminate
um
I don't know off the top of my head but
it could be interesting okay
um
yeah okay yeah I my talk is going to be
uh
probably more more applied than uh what
the theoretical folks in this room may
expect but we are drawing on a different
type of theory validity Theory from the
social sciences and uh we will get into
a few more kind of technical details in
the bit so so hopefully it will still be
of interest too
so we're gonna highlight these three
common reasons why validity can fail to
hold in practice
okay so we're gonna Begin by looking at
construct validity contract validity is
concerned with your whether the measure
captures what the researcher intended to
measure
and Scholars of modern validity Theory
often consider this to be the broad
overarching concern of validity research
in general
translating this to the algorithmic
decision making setting would require us
to assess whether the algorithm predicts
the intended quantity
well that might seem really simple to
assess and ensure uh actually in
practice there's often a big gap between
what we intend for the algorithm to
predict and what the algorithm actually
predicts
it's often hard to observe in the data
the quantity that we'd really like to
predict so for instance in the Child
Welfare setting we'd like to assess
child maltreatment or in criminal
justice context we'd like to predict
criminal activity but these outcomes are
not directly observable in data so
instead people use proxy outcomes like
criminal rearrest outcomes that are
readily available in administrative data
sets but these proxies can be harmful
when there's little construct validity
especially for vulnerable groups so in
the first talk today Michael discussed a
clinical predictive algorithm that used
healthcare costs to proxy for patient
needs
since healthcare costs are a poor
indicator of medical needs for groups
that historically faced barriers to
adequate medical care then using this
proxy can systematically underestimate
Health needs for black Nations
there are other common and even more
subtle types of misalignment that we
should be wary of
uh and to see this I'll discuss a class
of uh predictive algorithms we often see
in high stake settings that are tasked
with making a hypothetical prediction
that is they're intended to predict the
likelihood of an outcome under a
proposed decision
so for instance in healthcare we might
want to predict something like the
likelihood the patient will recover
without invasive treatment in child
welfare screening we'd want to predict
the likelihood of harm if the case is
not investigated
and we can mathematically Express this
goal of wanting to predict outcomes
under a proposed or hypothetical
decision using potential outcomes
notation from causal inference so I'll
write here why superscript T to D to
denote the potential outcome we would
observe under a hypothetical decision d
then our Target uh our prediction Target
is the likelihood of yd conditional and
features X
and it's really important to be precise
about this prediction Target because a
really common approach in practice that
just uses the observed features in your
data to predict the observed outcome
will in general not estimate this
quantity
and in fact it will build often build a
predictive model uh that's
systematically underestimates or
overestimates risk
these Target misalignments uh in other
words jeopardize the construct validity
of the model
the solution is to predict the potential
outcome that we actually care about and
we'll get into some details of how we
can use counterfactual estimation to do
things like this in a few slides
so even when we've properly specified
and estimated our Target
we can still have validity issues due to
other reasons
so to see this we'll turn now to
internal validity a concept from
experimental research which considers
the extent to which claims hold in a
particular study
so often these claims are causal so this
is asking us to what extent the
relationship identified in the study is
causal
translating this now to the algorithmic
decision making context would require us
to assess the degree to which the
predictive relationship that the model
learns corresponds to a plausible causal
relationship
an example where this does not hold
is the use of image processing on faces
to supposedly predict criminality
research has disproved the pseudoscience
that a person's facial features could
predict criminality so there's no reason
we should believe these algorithms are
valid predictors of crime
more generally to make meaningful
predictions we need data on relevant
predictive factors if there's no
plausible causal path be it direct or
indirect between the features and the
target outcome then we say there's
Target there's attribute misalignment
and including uh features where there's
no plausible plausible causal path in
the predictive model is going to
jeopardize the validity
in the example of using face images to
try to predict criminality we can't
assert a plausible causal path between
any feature and the target outcome so
this model would fail internal validity
because of that means one thing causes
another if they have the common cost
both of them just going up and them down
also yeah that also yeah so I'm yeah I'm
saying yeah any cosmopathic so yeah when
I said the word indirect referring to
going up and down um because there may
be some I mean maybe in some settings
you want to restrict it so say there has
to be a direct causal effect but in a
lot of settings where we're interested
in using algorithms that's probably too
strong we might be just interested in um
some kind of Association
um
the question is does it have to be can
it be confounded pathway or it doesn't
have to be so direct it's a direct Arrow
but it could be a mediated pathway does
it that do you allow confounded Pathways
so a common cause between between the
Target and the feature this thing yeah
yeah I so I do think there are settings
where a confounded pathway would be
allowable
um
what is the definition because
I mean that there's like any path on a
causal dag between the feature and the
outcome you care about
it yes exactly
yes yeah sorry I'm just I'm not what do
you mean by like how do we articulate
what plausible is like
like in this example if someone said
like oh oh will you just like haven't
thought of the right path like I mean
obviously like I think it's pretty well
accepted at this point that this is like
a pseudoscientific thing
but if someone said like oh oh you just
like haven't thought of the right thing
or the right feature to measure like
how do you argue that that's not
plausible
yeah I mean it's I think this is
naturally going to generate debate but I
think ideally the way like oh if
somebody says oh you haven't thought
about a path and I mean hopefully
they're a little more specific than just
saying like the right one they might say
like oh here's a possible path and then
you know you can write that down be
explicit about it and go out and maybe
get more data or do more research to see
if that exists so the idea is that you
should be able to kind of back up in
some way like provide some evidence
supporting this claim that there's a
plausible causal path
um and you know in the extreme case like
I picked here there's an overwhelming
amount of evidence disproving any of
those claims but for a lot of contexts
that we're interested in it's going to
be a lot more murky but I think it's
useful to still be very explicit about
what we're saying about plausible cause
of at this and then you open yourself up
for people to have a conversation and
actually disprove it or maybe go ahead
and conduct more research too but does
that kind of answer your question yeah
foreign
so another important type of validity
that we'll talk about today is external
validity which also comes from the
literature on experimental research
external validity concerns the degree to
which claims hold true in real world
settings
so in our algorithmic decision making
setting this requires for instance that
we assess how well claims about the
algorithm's performance and fairness
properties hold for real world contexts
in other words to what extent are
metrics on the sample training data
externally valid for the Target
population that the tool will be used on
and reasoning about this requires us to
assess when the data set does not
represent the target population
so we'll always of course have temporal
shift this is unavoidable but there may
additionally be sources of selection
bias or other distribution shifts that
we need to address
often we may observe outcomes
selectively for a biased sample of the
target population we already discussed
this consumer lending example where we
only observe repayment outcomes for
applicants whose loan was granted but we
can't we care about performance on the
full population that will use the tool
on
and population misalignment may also
rise in distribution shifts due to
domain transfer for example in many City
agencies there aren't enough resources
to develop in-house algorithms using
data collected locally so what's common
is that agencies might procure
algorithms from private companies and
the challenge is then how to ensure that
the data used to train the model
reflects the target population
a performance on the available data does
not accurately reflect performance in
the real world then our evaluation
metrics and fairness assessments will be
invalid and it's really important that
the fairness properties we assess are
externally valid on the target
population that we're actually going to
use the tool on
some potential methods uh to to correct
for this include rewiring or imputation
also known as outcome modeling or
methods that combine both of these
approaches like bias corrected doubly
robust methods
so how would something like this work
I'll show how to do this for calibration
since we've seen uh that in a couple of
the talks today but these techniques
going to be applied broadly
so calibration assesses the probability
the outcome y under the proposed
decision equals one for those whose
predicted risk is close to B and
calibration would require that that
quantity is itself supposed to be V
so in order to compute this it'll be
helpful to write uh this in terms of a
function mu that describes the
likelihood of the potential outcome
conditional on X you can think of this
as the counter factual version of the
Bayes optimal predictor
then we can identify these
counterfactual quantities in The
observed data under three assumptions
we assume we've measured all features
affecting both the decision and the
outcome
and that all cases have some probability
of getting the proposed decision
and lastly we assume that there's no
interference between units
these assumptions together identify the
outcome regression function as the
likelihood of The observed outcome y
conditional on X among those observed to
get the proposed decision
so this process we wrote this
hypothetical quantity in the top row in
terms of observable quantities in the
bottom row using these three identifying
assumptions
and then because we wrote calibration in
terms of this function mu we've also
identified calibration in terms of
observable quantities
the next step is to determine how to
estimate this which is where things like
re-wing into our imputation will come in
handy
so to get an estimate of calibration on
the full Target population we'll
estimate the two so-called nuisance
functions the outcome regression
function that we've seen as well as this
function Pi which is the treatment
assignment function also known as the
propensity score function
and we can use whatever we'd like to do
the regressions ideally something
flexible like non-parametric regression
or machine learning and then a simple
approach to estimating calibration on
the full population would just average
the outcome regression estimates
among those whose predictions are close
to V
but our estimate of mu here has some
bias we're not using the true mu just
our estimate of it so we'll also add
this bias correction term that takes the
form of an inverse probability weighted
residual
and we derived the form of this using
the influence function of the predictive
performance metric in this case
calibration
Okay so we've discussed these common
threats to validity and seeing that we
can address some of these misalignments
using statistical methods when Key
conditions holds more generally though
in practice it's typically not possible
to ensure perfect Target alignment
perfect attribute alignment and perfect
population alignment a central question
will concern the degree of this
misalignment so this kind of goes back
to the earlier question about you know
is there an example uh where this holds
perhaps in theory we can analyze that I
think in practice that's not going to
happen but we want to be really
thoughtful and explicit about where the
misalignments occur and to structure
deliberation around this question we
propose an architecture for a question
and answer based protocol so this would
be something akin to an IRB protocol for
human subjects research that we would
ask algorithm developers and owners to
complete before they build or deploy
decision making algorithms
so the first set of questions we
proposed would require respondents to
describe key constructs of Interest
including the decision-making objectives
the criteria across which the decision
is made and other decision points
surrounding the task
so here's a hypothetical example
response in the Child Welfare setting
intended to show how the respondent
might describe the setting the decision
makers the information available to them
as well as the proceeding of subsequent
decisions in the decision-making
criteria
we will next ask about construct
validity so this requires that we
identify the constructs involved the
ideal Target label and attributes
influencing it and the relationships
among them
in the paper we discussed one possible
way to prompt uh responses about this by
having respondents first determine what
the ideal outcome would be
then the protocol might ask questions to
compare and consider consequences of
misalignments between what the data
isn't readily available and what the
ideal outcome would be
to address internal validity the
protocol will ask respondents to provide
evidence for a defensible causal
relationship between features and the
target label
I'm very external validity which as a
reminder concerns the generalizability
of the model and its evaluation metrics
across context the protocol will require
respondents to describe the population
for which the data is available and how
this differs from the target population
that the tool will be used on
and we'll also ask them to Envision
potential real world implications for
these differences
so finally the protocol would ask the
respondents to discuss and document
trade-offs between validity and
competing considerations like
standardization and efficiency
so this is our proposed structure of a
validity centered deliberation protocol
but for this to be relevant and
accessible in practice will require more
research so this brings me to some new
opportunities for future work that my
collaborators and I are thinking about
and hopefully it might be of interest to
some of you
so ultimately what we want is to create
a resource that is accessible relevant
and useful in practice
and validity is multi-faceted as we saw
today aspects of validity may require
assessment by Frontline workers and
other domain experts or community
members
so this post is an exciting research
opportunity to investigate what kind of
artifacts what tools and processes are
going to be useful for structuring and
documenting deliberation on validity
and how those deliberations can include
representatives from all stakeholders
like impacted community members and
Frontline workers
and we also saw today how some
statistical methods can be used to
address certain validity issues when Key
conditions hold
what then is the best way to include
references and materials on these uh
statistical Concepts and solutions from
the academic literature in a form that
will be accessible and useful to
practitioners
so once we start unpacking these
questions there are a number of
interesting Dimensions to pursue
in ongoing work led by my amazing
collaborator Anna kawakami we are
conducting interviews with public
agencies to iteratively co-design the
protocol
and this work has generated some really
interesting questions and dimensions of
further inquiry
I also think it would be really
interesting to explore the intersection
here with multi-group fairness what role
can multi-group fairness play in this
process there's been some exciting work
on the connections between multi-group
fairness and domain adaptation that
relates to a number of the issues we
talked about today that I think we'll
hear more about uh tomorrow
I'm looking forward to further
discussion on these connections but for
today I will conclude by saying that I
hope I convinced you that centering
validity considerations can make
progress towards a more system
systematic evaluation of decision-making
algorithms
uh and for more information I point you
to our paper and IEEE said ml describing
a validity perspective for evaluating
the Justified use of decision making
algorithms where in addition to
elaborating on the validity issues we
discussed here today we also provide a
broader taxonomy and literature review
of criteria for justifiability including
Dimensions like value alignment and
reliability
I'd like to acknowledge my wonderful
advisors and collaborators and thank you
all for your attention
um and I think we have plenty of time if
there are any questions
that's very interesting college so a
couple of questions one is if you think
about the way these prediction models
are implemented at scale with these
industrial settings they're usually
trained to predict short-term outcomes
that are frivolous and then abundance
right things like clicks and they
everyone was training these models they
know that you don't care about
predicting clicks so then you run an ad
test to see whether you're moving some
long-term
how do I think about validity in these
types of settings like especially
constructability
yeah that's a good question
um so
yeah so um construct validity
um some people differ in what taxonomies
they will put on validity but a common
one will have types of contract validity
and so one type of construct validity is
convergent validity which I think might
relate to what you're saying and
convergent validity is is something you
can compute and it's a correlation
between
um the measure of Interest so you know
it would be I guess predicting clicks
and then some like round truth measure
so maybe when you run the EB test it
would be like you know whatever outcome
you're looking at whether it increases
Revenue to the company or something and
convergent validity would require that
correlation to be high
and then the kind of
like the on the other side you have
Divergent
um validity which would say if you know
that there's a concept you don't want it
to be so if we go back to like the SAT
example
um you might want to assess Divergent
validity there and that would say
you would compute the correlation
between
um people who you know the right answer
on this uh question and someone's
socioeconomic status and you would say
like that it shouldn't be measuring that
and if that's high you would uh fail the
test of Divergent validity foreign
testing they're probably looking at more
kind of fancy measures but I think
conceptually that's how we would
translate it over to the setting
so my second question is uh
once you start thinking about
these puzzle guns
um I guess if you want in for anything
about or say anything
so lying to yourself and and
articulating the assumptions you make
and arguing that these assumptions are
somewhat valid right so you know a lot
of the identifiability assumptions that
you see did
can you give me examples of to what
extent we can argue that they're
actually valid
um I think so if you're asking
like specifically when I was talking
about the counter-structural estimation
or even more broadly when we were
talking about requiring some plausible
causal paths
both of them
um foreign
I mean I would generally agree that you
know the exercise is being explicit
about the assumptions that you're making
and sometimes you know that those are
not going to hold but that you know
there's no better alternative or you
think the benefits still outrage the way
the risks
um and so that's kind of where I think
something like the protocol that makes a
lot of this really explicit and also in
con like in conjunction with the last
section where you are describing the you
know benefits you're hoping to get in
standardization or efficiency and then
it's this holistic decision about you
know whether the extent to what you
think the assumptions are violated you
know that's not great but you expect to
get a lot of benefits on the other side
um I I do think in most settings that's
going to be that kind of imperfect
trade-off
um
if
if you are really concerned about the
assumptions of the whole thing like
depending on what particular Point
you're concerned about it not holding
there are things that you can do uh so
you know like in the um uh when I was
presenting the assumptions that we were
using to compute metrics like
calibration uh you you need some
assumption on
the amount of confounding and I'll just
pull that up you need some assumption on
the amount of confounded you can't do
anything if you're not willing to make
any assumption
um this assumption one here but you can
do something much weaker than than
requiring that Independence to hold you
can um say that maybe there's a bound on
the amount of confounding and then um
you can still go through the same
process you can get something similar to
what we do here but instead you'll be
doing like lower and upper bounds um
uh
uh I'm not sure off the top of my head
what that would be for those claims
about the causal path but I guess yeah
um
yeah that would be interesting to think
is this sort of review and checklist
um intended to be adversarial because
they're like sort of someone arguing
against Civility and someone kind of
more defending it or is it sort of
does that make sense as a question is
there like a red team here kind of thing
yeah
um that is a cool idea uh
I had not been thinking about it that
way
so far we've been working with agencies
that are actually interested in doing
this the right way and thinking that you
know down the line maybe the way you
actually enforce this to be widely
adopted in places that that would say
they don't care about this that are
adversariable is through regulation
um but I think actually like think about
it on the small scale of having like an
adverse like a pro and it could be
interesting for trying to promote like
more deliberation like a delete style
setup
I could imagine that being very
reasonable and maybe in some like very
high stakes context like a hospital or
something yeah it's like
Your Design choices and then
review of this I had not thought about
the idea of having it's almost like
having a lawyer or something for either
side I think that's uh that's a cool
idea
or maybe all the examples are you decide
not to Launch
oh okay so so when deciding launch the
internet
and yes I was gonna say in practice we
have seen like sometimes welfare
agencies consider it start to build it
and then abandon the adoption which I
think is interesting I think it's
interesting to kind of understand that
process and what it was
made them decide to abandon it
um but it sounds like
sounds like that you would like
um it's good to know if that's all the
examples there are but
are there examples where
the protocol has kind of made things
better yeah so of course the protocol
doesn't exist once or we have it you
know deployed it once we do it would be
interesting to assess things like this
um but we have done these interviews
with agencies to understand their
current decision making processes and
I'm trying to think if there's some kind
of
um
uh useful so I I'm sure there must be
examples I will um
sure that and get back to you
um
I mean your example of taking the
analogies
SATs that'd be a positive example you're
updating the content of the test
so that it better represents what you're
trying to measure yeah I mean I I think
I don't yeah I mean perhaps if somebody
really wanted a positive example with
like modern machine learning it wouldn't
need it but I think exactly it's those
types of things that we would want like
you're identifying specific problems in
the system and that's kind of directing
ways um that you can improve it
um
so
I guess I can maybe construct a
hypothetical situation I'm sure there is
like the world when I look into it can
continue thinking about it
um but I do think it's you know what one
of the kind of outcomes that we might
hope that this would do is um
uh suggest ways that people could better
collect data for the for the um task at
hand so you know if you go back to that
the obermeyer at all
um clinical decision support algorithm
where they're using healthcare costs as
a proxy you know maybe if you had done
this protocol initially it would have
made it really apparent why that was a
problematic proxy and would have built a
compelling case for why the hospital
they're never going to be able to
identify exactly patient needs like
that's an unobservable thing but they're
much a better proxy outcomes that if
they would invest a little bit more
money you know a healthcare cost for
something that we're already recorded in
claims data so it's super cheap to get
but you could invest a little bit more
money in collecting better epoxies and
hopefully something like the protocol
would make a compelling case for why
it's important to do that
so it seems like you're Imagining the
collaboration between different kind of
individuals
there's more on the statistics or
machine learning side and so
stakeholders and perhaps some
main experts and then under like all of
them have different languages and
different goals and so how can you
imagine this interaction and also how do
you imagine balancing with the biases
that individuals have
this proxy will be better than that
proxy
perhaps there are viruses in a different
way
how can you imagine this inter I mean it
sounds like a very good and important
interaction between different
stakeholders
how do you mess up
how do you imagine facilitating it so it
will be productive and move things in
the right direction
in a better Direction yeah it's a good
question and I don't think we really
know the answer to it at this point
um though what seems like a reasonable
path it seems to me like you would first
want to ask these questions of the
people building the algorithm because
they would have the most knowledge about
like the data you know what's the
available outcomes what are the
predictors how it was collected so it
feels like that's where you'd want to
start
um but then the point the question and
the challenge would be how could you
make those answers like make it kind of
an iterative document and make those
answers available to other stakeholders
like the Frontline workers who would
then you know they would then like an
example we saw in child welfare maybe
they would say something like you know
we care a lot more about immediate needs
not these long-term proxies like whether
the child will later be placed into
foster care
um as well as the impacted community
members it will be hard to you know
engage everyone but perhaps their
representatives or activists who would
be important to have at the table but
exactly like what that form looks like I
think is an open question maybe like
going back to the suggestion about
having this kind of adversarial model
would be like one nice formalism for it
um but I think that's something that you
know hopefully like yeah we need a lot
of creative ideas and need to test these
actually out in the real world to see
um it's definitely a challenge to ask
these questions like in the talk today
there was a lot of jargon because
hopefully I think it's helpful to look
to other fields to kind of map the
landscape of these issues but ideally we
don't want to ask you know what's the
internal validity here you know because
we don't want to require people to
actually have this kind of background
um so that's where a lot of that's why
we're collaborating with people with
backgrounds at HCI and kind of are used
to these kind of mixed methods where you
actually go out and test this and do
like field work
um
even just having the people that design
it specifically answer to themselves
some basic questions
yeah I think so I I hope so that's I
think the first goal of this is actually
just walking people through and making
this really systematic so what we've
seen um when we've done these interviews
across agencies is that there's a lot of
heterogeneity and how nuanced their
thinking are like some really do think a
lot about these validity issues and
others um take for granted that you know
if they have high accuracy that they're
predicting the target construct that
they don't observe and so it's all it's
an opportunity to maybe kind of apply
you know best practices You observe in
one agency try to build these artifacts
that that make that more accessible and
something that people in those other
agencies where there's room for
improvement can use to start
um having more nuanced thinking but then
hopefully eventually if you can make
that document available to the public
then that provides more opportunities to
have other people participate in the
conversation
actually I have a question about like
what is the what do you think like the
regulatory perspective is on this like
do you imagine that like for example
Regulators would be like oh this is the
degree of validity in this current like
private sector company's algorithm but
this could be the potential level of
validity it could achieve like
um yeah how do you think about like how
this kind of like instead of from
building the protocol perspective from
like kind of auditing or checking the
validity perspective that like
would be realizable
and some type of type of regulatory way
yeah so
how I've been thinking about the way
regulation would play a form in this
it's hopefully you know what we
eventually have a protocol that is
useful it's accessible uh it seems to
work on on pilot data and then you have
regulations that require all agencies to
do it and you have this independent
review board that would kind of review
an Insight off of it like how we do have
for irbs
um the question of you know I think can
you be more quantitative and say like
what degree of validity is it required I
think is an interesting one I think
there's always that challenge like good
heart's law right as soon as you know
you have some way to quantify it then it
becomes a less meaningful measure and
people can kind of be the measure
um but that's not to say that it's that
they're I think there could be some
value in having some you know
quantitative measure as part of this
process I'm just skeptical that that
should be the main piece
um
but I'm open to yeah some of my I think
collaborators take a a more they're more
Pro uh having some kind of quantitative
measure of validity so we could see
where that goes or if you uh if you have
ideas for it
was there no
okay so let's say thank the speaker
again
during 10 minutes